Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this is my
Teen Wolf episode 11 video.
Next week is the finale so after I get through
all the craziness from this week I’ll explain
when Season 5 is going to start.
Right now there are a number of ways the finale
can still go down, so I’ll add my favorite
theories after my review.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
But here’s my top 5 wtf moments.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay.
Here we go.
Number 5 - Deaton is Back
Seth Gilliam has been filming Walking Dead
Season 5, that’s why he hasn’t been in
every episode this season.
People die way more frequently on that show,
so the odds he’d totally bail on Teen Wolf
are very slim.
Daniel Sharman for instance, asked specifically
to not be killed off when he left to do Originals.
So actors can always come back if they’re
not confirmed dead.
I totally dug the Hannibal Lecter thing he
and Valick had going on.
I’m gonna go ahead and guess he wasn’t
a medical doctor.
If you didn’t catch the Trepanation reference,
Trepanning is the practice of drilling or
scraping a small piece of the skull away to
expose your outer brain matter as a means
to relieve pressure.
There’s evidence that neolithic humans practiced
it.
That was around 10,000 BC.
Yeah, long time ago.
It was the era when humans started to develop
tools.
Apparently so that the could use them to bore
holes in peoples heads.
Teen Wolf History lessons for the win!
The reason Valick did it seemed more a way
to expose his third eye whenever he manifested
psionic powers.
If you didn’t notice, the place where Deaton
went in the dream state was the same underground
temple in mexico where Kate was hiding out
and where they found Derek in the premiere.
They haven’t fully explained Kate’s magic
yet, so I’m hoping the finale clears up
some of the mechanics.
Other major reveal was the woman deaton loved.
I’m guessing that was Derek’s mother.
That sounds like a teaser for a season 5 story
unless I’m forgetting something.
on to Number 4 - Derek doesn’t care about
the money
Mostly because the money was never his, it’s
all peter’s like Stiles thought.
Derek’s money for all intents and purposes
has always been safe.
He owns the loft and the rest is all in a
series of bank accounts.
I love that he suggests Scott keep the money.
It sounds like Derek doesn’t trust Peter
with it.
Which makes me feel like Stiles Eichenhouse
debt wasn’t forgiven, Scott paid it off
and manufactured the letter to Stiles dad.
Unless Stiles was faking and he wrote the
letter.
Either way I don’t think Peter is getting
that money back.
I thought for a minute when derek was explaining
he owned the building that the show was teasing
it might move Scott in as a way to solve some
money problems.
Like, we don’t need to fix our roof because
we live in Derek’s building rent free now.
I don’t think that’s going to happen,
Scott and Kira’s date was really the follow
up to that.
That’s as close as they’re getting to
living together in the loft.
On to Number 3 - Liam is still Flipping out
It’s pretty clear they’re preparing him
for a big turnaround in the finale.
The full moon is a problem because he still
can’t control his shifts and it’s only
24 hours away.
That’s just the show saying the finale will
be a full moon so everything will be totally
crazy.
I’m going to be happy to see Liam not space
out anymore.
It’s one of the few stories this season
that I haven’t had fun with.
He is the new guy, so I get why he can’t
just automatically be an amazing werewolf.
He has to overcome a struggle to earn his
wolf stripes.
Usually surviving traumatic events together
is what brings everyone together.
Which Kate and Peter are more than happy to
supply.
There was this whole thing going on in the
episode where moments kept reminding us of
the relationship between fear, anger and strength.
Liam going all bro-dude in the weightroom
was a good reminder that the more angry he
is, the stronger he gets.
Like sliding scale of Hulk.
I’m betting that in the finale he’ll find
the motivation to stay pissed off enough to
destroy the berserkers.
Scott will always be the most powerful because
of his alpha abilities, but Liam is the next
most strong because of his rage face.
I was happy to see Brett help him out.
There’s a chance he might help out in the
finale too.
Especially if Satomi gets involved.
On to Number 2 - Peter Wants Malia To Kill
Kate
This got me really excited at the thought
she might go through with it.
Not because she wants to help Peter, but because
she’ll have to save Scott.
They’ve already established how protective
of Scott she is and she’s not fully integrated
into human society.
Character-wise, she’s in a limbo state where
she could be totally copacetic at the thought
of killing a villain as bad as Kate.
She might even feel like it’s justified.
Peter giving off his creepo vibes is really
the only thing that made the plan sound sinister.
But who else loved Peter’s reaction to the
Desert Wolf.
Positive she’s you’re mother.
I can’t wait to learn about that history.
I doesn’t sound like we’ll meet her in
the finale.
At least by season 5.
I’m hoping that Malia goes through with
the kill, then spends most of season 5 dealing
with what she’s done.
And it takes her mother to help set her right
again.
Like the remorse for killing kate will be
more than Stiles alone can help her with.
It will be something she needs her mother
for.
I can already imagine the awkward family dinner
with Peter, The Desert Wolf and Malia.
I wonder if Derek would just go hide out and
avoid the whole thing all together.
and my Number 1 WTF Moment - Kate Turns Scott
Into A Berserker
Or at least she’s going to turn him into
something that looks like a berserker.
It’s still so unclear as to what’s involved
in that.
I’m guessing Deaton will explain that part.
Remember though Scott went crazy Alpha form
last week, I think that was just the beginning.
I’m hoping we get to see him full on hulk
out Peter Alpha style and just smash the hell
out of the temple.
Presumably Deaton knows what’s happened
to Derek too, and I’m guessing saving scott,
fixing derek and liam fixing himself will
all tie in with Malia killing kate.
I don’t know that just killing her will
fix everything, it wouldn’t be that simple,
but I’m wondering if Kate is using Derek’s
mojo to power the berserker transformations.
Like that’s the energy consumed to transform
them.
Scott’s arc this season has been dancing
around the idea of him becoming a monster.
Him hallucinating killing liam in his dream
state makes a lot more sense now.
That might have been a premonition for whatever
he’ll be like under kate’s influence.
If Peter is going to try and steal his powers
I think the circumstances of his death are
important.
So if his friends kill him like Kate wants,
I think that will botch Peter’s plan.
Which might be why Peter is enlisting Malia’s
help.
Just as a backup.
Anyway, let me know what your biggest wtf
from the episode was.
And do you actually think kate will be able
to turn Scott.
Or was that final moment a total fake out.
Like maybe Scott will hulk out at the last
second.
Here are a couple of my bigger predictions.
Peter will not take Scott’s Power, but he
will steal someone’s power.
Malia might not end up killing Kate, but she
will do something to mentally scar herself.
And Scott will go into his full on Alpha Form.
He’ll look like a version of what Peter
looked like.
Super huge.
And we’ll finally see Parrish manifest his
power.
I know I didn’t mention it in the episode,
but his eyes flashed red, so we’ll finally
find out what his powers are.
I’m guessing they’ll be fire-related.
The title of the finale is The Broken Spell.
So it implies they’ll break the spell Kate
put on Derek too.
Overall I gave the episode a B plus, I liked
the Trashy Romance novel motif they set up.
They kind of dropped that about halfway through
the episode.
The Kira/Scott date was were it ended.
I tried to read the titles of all those books
Doctor Valick had, I only saw “The Afternoon
Wife, Love’s Passion, Hawaiian Honeymoon”.
Maybe there’s a teaser in there.
Like between the finale and Season 5 some
of the characters will go on vacation to hawaii,
the afternoon wife could be a reference to
malia’s mother.
I guess you could also just think of them
as visual references for all the trashy romance
novel moments in the episode, like when it
jumped from couple to couple.
Derek and Braeden, Stiles and Malia, and scott
and kira.
I could totally see Braeden taking Derek to
hawaii during the off season.
I think the episodes in season 4 have done
a really good job of developing each of the
characters in a way that gives them places
to go in season 5 and beyond.
I don’t see the show going past 7 seasons
but if they can gain the type of audience
Supernatural has, they can go forever.
Especially if they can keep bringing in new
characters like Liam.
Dylan Sprayberry could totally take over as
an alpha someday if Scott had a reason to
leave town (like if Tyler Posey left the show
for some reason).
That’s a good thought to end on.
How many seasons do you think Teen Wolf will
get?
I expect to at least see season 6.
They wouldn’t have upped the order from
12 to 20 between season 4 and 5 if MTV didn’t
feel confident about the show.
I’m pretty much moved into my new place,
so my finale video will post monday night.
On time for once, be sure to subscribe to
get it in case you’re just now finding me.
In the meantime, you can click here for last
week’s episode and you can click here to
start getting ready for Arrow Season 3 and
The Flash.
Those shows are coming back in october.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!